- Speaking of walking, I heard
that you asked your father
on "Young Rock," the character,
to take a walk with you.
- Yes.
- You wanted to do that
with your dad and you didn't get it
and so is that what happened?
- So, yes.
So this is Joseph Lee Anderson
and he's the man who plays
my dad on "Young Rock."
And my dad was a professional wrestler,
bad dude in the game,
one of the first black champions
in the world of pro wrestling.
And my dad passed away
suddenly two years ago,
and I never had a chance
to say goodbye to him.
And when somebody (snaps) goes like that,
and plus we had a
complicated relationship,
so when he died, I was
like, man, there's just,
we had more talking to do.
We had more stuff
to take care of,
- Yeah.
- unanswered questions, man.
And so I still reconcile
with that still today and-
- Yeah.
- but yet this surreal show,
"Young Rock," has been shooting
for almost three years.
I've never met any of the
actors because of Covid.
So we
- What?
Yeah, dude.
We just shot in Memphis three weeks ago.
- Yeah.
I shot all my stuff,
and the cast flew over
and I finally got a chance
to meet all the cast,
and this guy, Joseph Lee Anderson,
who plays my dad, and he,
if you ever see a picture
of my dad, it's so striking.
And I hugged this guy
and it was so emotional,
I didn't want to let him go,
'cause it's like hugging your,
- Aw.
- the one who you lost.
And so I've never took a walk with my dad,
because he's like, my dad was like,
he's like a dude who
was stunted emotionally.
- A dude bro. That's what we called 'em.
- A dude bro.
- Yeah.
- He was like a dude bro.
- We called them dude bros. (laughs)
- So we never had these moments,
so, I told him, I said,
"Hey man, would you mind
taking a walk with me?"
He's like, "Yeah, let's just take a walk."
So I took a walk. It was
like walking with my old man.
That's so cool.
- It was really special. Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- I'm sorry that you
didn't get, I never got
that either, with my father.
He passed away.
- Oh really?
Yeah. But sometimes it's hard.
Sometimes you try and it doesn't work.
And then sometimes I do
feel like people come
into your lives to kind of
represent maybe what was missing.
- Yes.
- And then you have to be open to that.
- I feel like,
I mean, that's how my therapy sessions go.
(both laugh)
- Yes. No, no, no.
You're right.
- That's my life.
- Also, what I feel like is,
what's interesting is,
we had a complicated relationship,
but now that he's gone,
I feel like we're closer.
- Yeah.
- In this crazy way,
where I could just talk
to him at any point.
And also what I realized is,
I find myself more and more
thinking about the good stuff.
- Yeah.
- And not the stuff that
was kind of funky, you know?
- Yeah.
(audience applauds)